you know now that has come time for me
to do a top 10 for the 10th doctor I
wonder for if the 9th doctor should have
done a top 9 then for the 11th the top
11 that heck with it too gimmicky
[Applause]
[Music]
yes folks it's time I have gone back and
rewatched every single one well except
for later appearance and day of the
doctor but that's that's the some thing
but all of the episodes that can be
truly be said to be Tenth Doctor
episodes of new whoo
I've done the entire Tennant run so now
I need to come up with my top ten and
this was tough and it was tough for a
few reasons the the top like some things
have shifted around since last time I
did this and there are some things on
here that weren't on here last time and
some things that were on it the last
time I did it that aren't gonna make it
this time
I though honestly in an odd way it was
kind of the bottom that was the hardest
for me to fill in because there were a
number of episodes like with elements
and aspects that I loved but also other
stuff that I'm like yeah but there's
that and so I had to balance and figure
out what struck the best chord overall
in terms of the things that worked for
me how much was it diminished by the
things that didn't and really come down
to really close calls but let's get to
it that is more than enough preamble for
me so starting at number 10 Smith and
Jones so this is easily the best start
to a series so far in modern era whoo
and actually continuing through series
four I say so far I mean of the ones
I've revisited of the Davies era this is
the strongest opener because it's a
great jumping on point the doctor
explains who he is you get the gist of
what's going on with him the kind of
she deals with we introduced Martha we
get why the doctor gets along well with
her what the appeal of her is to him to
bring her along it gives us a fun little
romp of an adventure we got space rhinos
it's got a little bit of everything it's
fun it's wacky
it's got great it's a great just sort of
chemistry trial for these two characters
it's a really good piece of work number
nine this is your reminder that I count
two parters as a single story so this
one goes to army of ghosts and doomsday
now doomsday is the stronger of these
two halves but I do like this whole
story so this made the list while I
ended up not quite putting on the stolen
earth in journey's end again not because
I did like it please keep mine just cuz
it wasn't a top-10 doesn't mean like
don't like that it just means that when
it came down to it like what has the
stuff that hits me best because
journey's end has the exit of Donna
which I adore in his amazing but tenants
also honestly kind of off a little bit
in that story and things just click a
little bit but every year for me and we
have rose on the other side of that wall
and that hurts and the best way not
quite to the level of Donna but that's a
good hurt right there plus Daleks versus
Cybermen like how can you not just have
fun with that number eight the entry
that surprised me for making it on here
a waters of Mars this is one that has
vehemently not entered into my top ten
previously but I better understood what
works about it and I was better able to
leave behind the things that other
people praised about it that don't quite
click for me with this episode and
realize that's not a fault of the
episode that's just a fault
well not a fault but that's just a
disagreement of this one aspect so like
when people tell me it's great because
it's scary maybe it was to them and I'm
not trying to diminish that but it never
has been to me and I don't think the
horror level works nearly as well as
some other stuff but you want to bring
down to character drama and the doctor's
own personal arc and pushing him to the
degree that he goes by the end of this
story
does that masterfully it's also one of
the better-looking episodes in terms of
the way it's shot and the atmosphere of
it I still think the flood is kind of
overrated as a villain they're solid and
they work they're not nearly scary some
people say but the thing is I came to
realize on this tree watch being scary
is not the point of this episode the
point of this episode is to push the
doctor and for us to see why him taking
that degree of ownership and control
over time and people's fates is a bad
idea
and it does that really well number
seven some people consider this me to be
a breaking of the rule that I count
multiple partners is a single story but
I choose to parse this out as its own
separate thing different from the two
part of that followed I am talking about
utopia yes the introduction while
reintroduction of the master in the
first time we get him in modern who
we've got derek jacobi so wonderful
sweet affable immediately likable and
then that turn oh so good and the
tension of that and more than just that
it's a really neat setup you know where
where do you run when there's literally
nowhere else to run to you are at the
end of time you are at the end of the
universe where is there to go but
there's still hope and you still got a
try and the moments of Jack like talking
with the doctor he's like in that room
with the radiation and it won't kill him
but the doctor ask him from the other
side of the store do you want to die and
Jack not knowing how to answer that and
Martha's little moments aside with
chantho there's a lot of wonderful
little things that make this episode of
joy all the way through before the big
twist got punch at the end oh yeah I
love it
number six one that other people might
not put as highly as me but I really do
adore this one this is a comfort food
episode for me school reunion this was
my introduction to Sarah Jane Smith this
is anthony Stewart head as the villain
which is Glory's and I will for as long
as the man is still working as an actor
we'll continue to be annoyed that mr.
Finch has not come back as a villain
because he was the first villain really
I would say sis other than the the Dalek
Emperor or maybe the definitely the
first one facing Tennant where he felt
like a match for him when he stands up
to him when the two of them talk to each
other you feel like oh we got to be
careful about this guy you don't get
that from most of the one-time villains
and Doctor Who especially against Emmet
telling commands the screen pretty well
anthony Stewart head can match him b4b
and it is so good and then you know just
k9 back that's fun
Micky realizing he's the 10 dog which is
so sweet and kind of adorable and I know
there's little things about this and the
special effects are not only dated they
weren't exceptionally great at the time
but I like the feel and the vibe of this
I think he's got some great fun dialogue
and just the dynamics of the characters
and the performances this I just I never
get tired of seeing this number 5 what
is basically the gimme
everyone's gonna put this on their top
10 for Tennant it's just a question of
where is where I'm putting it talking
about bullying this is the
quintessential dr.light story the doctor
is barely in it and it doesn't matter it
is still Doctor Who it still feels like
Doctor Who it is still it has with the
twisting of the time and the scariness
of what's going on and getting this
other perspective of the end stay with
that perspective of the people who are
here and are touched by the doctor but
don't actually get to go with him and
aren't with him on any part of this
adventure they have an adventure they
have a part in it but it's not with him
and getting to see that is really just
very cool and the notion of the weeping
angels besides that is pretty inventive
and I really do like it I mean I
honestly think the what's scary about it
is the execution the concepts just kind
of okay but then the execution of it
visually that's what makes it scary
works really well terrific performances
by a cast of characters that we don't
get to see again but they're all great
bringing their a-game in this good stuff
and that brings us up to number four the
impossible planet and the Satan pit this
one's always going to
a top-tier one for me for a number of
reasons first of all I love the tone
I love the mood I love horror in a space
setting it's it's this cosmic horror
sort of thing with this whole idea of
this thing is it the devil is it
something else is it what inspired the
myths of the devil what is this thing
what is going on and none of this should
be happening and the guest cast is so
this is one of the best guest cast ever
and definitely in terms of a base under
siege sort of story because they have a
wonderful set firmed up dynamic between
each other all these characters they
behave like they've been working with
each other for ages it's great it's
established for a poor and the doctor
and row is also doing wonderful stuff
and also I'm also kind of a sucker for
this because it was the Satan pit
catching that randomly on TV in London
while on my honeymoon that I first
hooked in and like okay I need when I
get back home I gotta start checking out
of the stuff so I'm always gotta be
sucker for for that besides but I don't
even need to be a sucker for it because
it's good it's really good I love the
tone the atmosphere looks great
fantastic performances and music unlike
anything else in the entirety of the
show ah good so here's where things
start to get shaken up a little bit
because we're now gonna get to the one
that last time I did my top ten Tennant
stories came in at the number one spot
now it hasn't really gone down in my
estimation it's just a few other things
ended up being raised up above it after
this recent rewatch so that means right
now I get to talk about science on the
library the forest of the Dead so much
to love Donna love her and she gets to
break my heart with the pain of losing
her children children that she doesn't
really have but to her that loss feels
real and the Vashta Nerada tour again
terrific concept really well executed
for the scares of it I love Colin salmon
as dr. moon he he really rides the line
between affable and yet somehow vaguely
insidious the introduction of River Song
and regardless of whatever you think
about her as a character down the line
her introduction is spot-on for what she
is doing and
especially if you're coming back to this
after seeing more of her story you feel
that pain for her at looking at the
doctor realizing he looks right past me
he doesn't know me I don't mean anything
to him yet and seeing that way on her
and to realize she's giving that
performance before having done any of
the other stuff or you really knowing
what was gonna come and only having
vague hints of it what an astounding
performance from Alex Kingston also
again a really good established group a
bit like impossible planet and Satan pit
not quite to that level but again great
dynamics between the groups terrific
performances fun twisty story and I just
I every elements of this I love it so
number two human nature and the family
of blood it's not easy when the entire
pitch of your show is look at the
incredible things that this person to do
and then take those all the way make
them completely ordinary and still have
it be really compelling and I like I
really like that John Smith is a
distinctly different character from the
doctor there's elements of the doctor in
there and obviously you know it's
Tennant who looks like him but he's a
different person he behaves differently
he has different reactions he is visibly
scared by a lot of what's going on and
the way that he feels the way that he
processes it's all very different and
Joan Redfern is a terrific character
with a great rapport with Tennant and
also you can feel the hurt from her when
she meets the doctor and she says can
you change back yes will you know oh and
then there's the family of blood
wonderful creepy off-putting
performances and I love the way that
they talk I just this whole thing of
them sniffing it out and of course we
have our little sneaky introduction of
the fob watch which will pay off again
later on the bill up - it is great
Martha also gets some really good stuff
to do in this there there are a number
of episodes in series 3 where I feel
like Martha is
misused or sidelined or used to recycle
things that rose didn't they even kind
of hang a lampshade on that but I really
like this because what is done with
Martha in this story could not have been
done with another companion so it's a
really great showcase for Martha as well
everything is clicking but it does not
take the number one spot the number one
spot needs to go to midnight I am always
very reticent to use words like flawless
but honest to god I wouldn't change a
thing pretty much everything else even
the ones right below this I'd have one
thing that I tweaked one little element
that I'd alter slightly this
the way that this entity takes over this
woman the way that all the people on
board this bus basically react and how
their attempts to cope with what's going
on evolve over time and it just is very
revealing about who they are as people
and you can watch this over and over and
over again and each time focus in on a
different character and learn more about
them realize more about who they are and
how they are processing and how they are
dealing or failing to deal with what it
is that's going on and this thing is the
perfect foil the perfect flow for the
tenth doctor specifically to face
because his greatest asset his mouth his
ability to talk his way out of stuff or
to talk information out of people or to
just stall for time by talking it's
being used against him it won't save him
in fact it will doom him this is so good
Davies knocked it out of the park with
this script the performances further
elevated it it's astounding
and I think personally that it's the
best Tenth Doctor episode that said I've
reread just this before if I ever do it
again in the future it'll probably get
rearranged again but for right now
that's my list that's my top ten what is
yours
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons links like and
subscribe also check out my patreon it
is greatly appreciated it helps me cover
my bills and hopefully make the channel
better down the line in addition to that
I've got links to a book and my socials
etc so go ahead and click on those
things they'll take your places but you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day folks you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]